uh what do you cook like what's your
go-to dish
oh I so it's so funny because I put in a
song uh pasta Lobster but it's actually
like my go-to dish now like so the
lobster pasta is what your go-to is yeah
you gotta try it it's so good can you
cook up like any special sort of ramen
noodles like if you were to make a pack
of noodles yeah and you put like the egg
and the shrimp
and like the green onions and stuff it's
like it's Ramen
some people will put like uh just hot
sauce and like melted cheese and cheese
yeah you never put cheese in your
noodles
y'all put cheese in y'all noodles
I do oh no
you just put like uh so look the you
know is it like a single cheese slice it
could be
friend I don't like that and then look
and then you just stir it and then it
melts into the noodles
I don't like that food then you get
Tapatio hot sauce then some soy sauce
it's soy sauce too yeah and then you put
the beef pack in
and a little bit of butter
I swear to God I swear to God it's good
I swear that sounds horrible
it definitely sounds like diarrhea
because our screaming and I don't
pretend you're a bit it sounds like
prison
it sounds like spread
it is funny because like I didn't know a
subconsciously as a kid I was just
making spread the whole time and so I
started to see these rappers put
together their spreads and I was like I
was eating that when I was a kid
shout out to my parents let me eat like
a [__] convict when I was 11. I'm
still trying to figure out what a spread
is so when you're in jail they'll
they'll they'll take like because you
know in jail there's like limited stuff
you can get your hands on right so
they'll take like noodles they'll take
like sardines or tuna they'll just put a
bunch of [__] together and then they'll
mash it together
right and then they'll cook it and then
it's like a they call it a spread I went
to jail for four days why
and it was on Memorial Day weekend so so
everybody was on vacation yeah what was
that like and they it was like a it was
actually in Douglasville Georgia and so
like they had everybody
like I just had a failure to appear for
speeding nothing crazy nothing crazy but
I was in there with women that was about
to do 15 years right so it was not fun
I've been to jail twice it's not fun
either yeah now let me ask you this when
you went to jail
did you notice anybody using the roll of
toilet paper as a pillow in the holding
cell no
no I don't think I wanted I don't think
I talked to anybody I just literally I
didn't eat yeah because you don't want
to [__] in front of everybody no I just
that looks disgusting no I didn't eat
either
they give you like a bag of peanut
butter no they didn't they didn't give
me none of that they gave me were you
even holding cell with a bunch of random
people yeah well it was just one other
person so I was in a holy cell with like
20 other dudes yeah
and I was like I am not [__] in here
so they gave you food I was like I need
nothing I took a roll of toilet paper
used it as a pillow in the corner and
just waited
it was terrible I don't like I don't
understand like when people go to jail
and they get out and then they go back
yeah it doesn't make sense yeah why did
it happen to you twice why why did you
go to jail the first time oh the first
time I went to jail was because I uh I
gave false information to a police
officer oh
and the second time I went to jail was
because uh the case is still open so we
won't talk about it okay okay okay
well cool but yeah it wasn't anything
crazy but uh yeah jail sucks and then
they knew my music too at the time
recently what was that last year last
Memorial Day you should have been doing
a show or something I did so okay so
actually so this sounds so funny because
it was like I just said when people go
back so I've been there twice but but
the first time I was just like only
there for it no I was only there for
like a couple hours because I had a show
and my manager came and she got me and
that was the first time I was like what
the I'm never doing that again like I
hated that and when you spin the block
and then I went
I I just wasn't I had moved and I forgot
to change my address and I never got the
ticket yeah so they and I and I pulled
over and I was confident I'm like also
why am I being pulled over like I'm I'm
good was it one of the tickets where you
drove past the camera and it took a
picture of you or what did you get like
a no it was like
it was like a year a year ago and I was
like speeding on this like uh it was a
back road and nobody was driving there I
was just going to pick up my food was it
like a one of those Highway Patrol guys
just parked yeah and the lights was off
in the South I tell you what in the
South those [__] highway patrol guys
be camped out
and then he he came up screaming out the
window like do you know I could take you
to jail right now you guys are going
fast
yeah when you're like uh I was I can't
even lie I'm like he really can't take
me to jail right now because like why
would you go that fast you know if you
gave a Postmates driver a chance you
wouldn't have to drive to get your own
food you just have your man do it he
would be kind of poor but you know
um
you know
yeah
what's your preferred like uh Cuisine if
you were ordering food
um I like a filet mignon cooked medium
Jesus with a lobster tail and some
mashed potatoes 100 bucks every time on
Postmates yeah actually I I ordered I
actually ordered that with like the
cream corn and stuff just on a random
day what's under 20 that you would like
okay how about this what's your favorite
fast food chain Popeyes but they kind of
expensive now you ain't getting that
under 20 now what are you getting at
Popeyes are you getting a family meal
well if I'm ordering it from doordash
you know that oh yeah doordash to add
everything up that's fair that's fair
that's fair and I'm usually ordering it
from doing this so do you guys have
Raising Cane's in Atlanta no well yeah
no it's in Athens Georgia and it's like
two hours away have you had it yeah it's
amazing it's so good the sauces but we
have Zaxby's which is like a it's like a
yeah just like y'all have college junior
we have Hardies it's like well that's
literally the same thing Hardee's and
Carl's Jr is the same thing okay it's
the same company
I just thought it was Zaxby's in raising
Kansas they're different but they're the
same at the same time yeah yeah I mean
the same kind of sauce they have more
options yeah but they do yeah but they
do have the same kind of like sauce and
the chicken tenders what are your
thoughts on McDonald's
McDonald's still good to me I just want
to make sure we're on the same page
double cheeseburger you put fries in
your burger I used to I don't do that no
more just give me the fries with the
salt you got to put the fries in the
burger no
why do you eat like that
it's so good you stuff the I get the
number nine it's two cheeseburgers then
you put the fries in the burgers there's
another way to do it and then you get
the McChicken the spicy McChicken for a
dollar they don't have that number they
don't got it where you're at they got it
where I'm at they don't got no spice to
make chicken in Atlanta they brought it
back
and they brought the orange High sea
back which is they got rid of it for
like a year I never really drank that
I'm more of like a fruit punch Coke yeah
well McDonald's Coke is uh you know it's
God's Coke
okay if there is a God if there is a God
would drink McDonald's Coke
he wouldn't drink normal I thought it
was spray I thought this is right okay
it's both